when the President President Obama
mentioned the Sputnik moment seeing that
we are losing a competitive edge to the
Chinese and others said this is a new
Sputnik moment and then he gave a list
of things we should do which included
like higher speed internet and and light
rail I'm thinking no no in energy
independence that's not a Sputnik moment
we should have those things anyway
Sputnik moments you reserved those four
grand visions that take your mind body
and soul to places that no one had
previously dreamed Sputnik moments are
cases where you invent tomorrow I'm not
old enough to remember 1957 but there
are certainly plenty people among us who
do and when Soviet Union launched
Sputnik that was a Sputnik moment this
was a our sworn enemy the Communists and
we had our own state of self-assessment
that we were technologically proficient
you know we won the war our
manufacturing was back in place and
here's this country that we were telling
the whole world that we were better than
they were in every way that mattered and
bam out comes a satellite our response
as we created NASA first we went berserk
then we created NASA a year later we
redoubled our efforts in science and
technology and engineering and that
would shape the identity of the United
States from the end of the 1950s through
the 1970s the Sputnik city of that
moment I think comes from the fact
whether or not the public knew this the
military folks knew it that Sputnik was
a hollowed out intercontinental
ballistic missile shell they took out
the warhead and put in a radio
transmitter that went beep beep the
military folks knew that if they could
put a radio transmitter in a ballistic
missile shell and flied over our heads
that they have the new high ground so in
that case the Sputnik moment was a
military one and it was clear that
technology and science would be what
would enable nations
to take the lead and the high ground
right now where we in America where for
slowing down or maybe everyone else is
just speeding up but the effect is we've
lost our edge we've lost our leadership
position when President Obama said in a
Sputnik moment in fact we will
rejuvenate the space program spectrum in
fact is not dead it's just kind of
smoldering back there one of them is
will be back to Mars in the 2030s 2030s
maybe early as the late 2020s who's
going to be President on what budget so
that's a nice thing to listen to in a
speech because he's thinking about the
future but that's not a future that's
actually within reach that anyone can
act upon
I don't like Sputnik moments I'd rather
have been the leader all along why do we
have to be shocked into being motivated
to lead why don't we just lead all the
time and maybe that's just unrealistic
maybe that's just not human nature maybe
we have to feel threatened in order to
act so yes Sputnik moments work and if
we can't lead all the time let it be a
Sputnik moment that kick-starts our
heart back beating again but I can't
help but be a little disappointed that
we haven't stayed there that we have to
have to play catch-up if we're going to
catch up at all
you